bonsoir Gina Lollobrigida vous avez un
rapport affectif à la France très
particulier vous aviez tourné déjà
beaucoup de films quand c'est la France
qui vous a consacré vedette oui en effet
oui je dois la France mon succès
cinématographique c'était commencer par
hasard mais le succès c'est venu
international c'est commencer en France
avec Gérard
cette année on a fêté à Sarlat cette
avènement tout la ville a été en fait
pour les 40 ans de femmes fortes et
quand vous avez tourné ce film de
Christian Jacques est-ce que vous aviez
l'impression que ça allait être un
tournant et un tremplin formidable pour
votre carrière non non je ne savais pas
à tel point que quand le film était
terminé les producteurs nous skin il m'a
téléphoné
à Rome mais disant Gina peut-être il
changer les noms j'ai dit pourquoi il
m'a dit tu sais Lolo brigitalolo ça veut
dire en France
jolie seins oh j'ai dit la première moi
je vais pas poser de questions là-dessus
alors j'ai dit ben change-le
il m'a dit quel nom je dis n'importe
quoi parce que à ce moment-là je n'ai
vraiment je ne pensais pas que je
continueai à faire du cinéma et mais on
avait fait déjà les génériques alors
pour une question d'économie on n'a pas
changé les noms parce qu'on devrait
faire tous les génériques comme ça j'ai
gardé cette nom que c'est des ma
naissance je l'ai pas inventé c'est pas
possible de faire le cinéma avec un nom
pareil mais
quelquefois le destin décide lui-même le
succès oui ou non et alors mais voilà
cette allée un peu bien je crois votre
passion du cinéma elle remonte à la à
l'enfance parce que votre vous aviez
séduit un projectionniste pour que il
vous permette de rentrer dans le sac à
cabine pour vous diffuser des films et
il vous est même des petits montages
avec les plus beaux baisers de Gary
Cooper les patins
il abîmait tous les films avant qu'il
partait dans une autre ville et après il
est monté tout ensemble et c'était une
projection pour
nous c'était des petites moi j'avais
quoi huit ans 10 ans et alors c'était
une projection le dimanche matin pour
nous avec tous les morceaux de tous les
films que le projectionniste abîmé pour
pour nous quand j'étais à hollywo j'ai
raconté tout ça à agarico
c'était assez amusant vous avez été
certainement une des une des stars les
plus adulées du cinéma avec des choses
invraisemblables qui nous paraissent
aujourd'hui invraisembla quand vous
étiez reçu en Argentine il y a un train
qui a fait marche arrière pendant un
kilomètre parce que des gens étaient sur
la voie pour pouvoir passer etc est-ce
que vous avez la nostalgie de cette
sorte de délire autour de vous non moi
je me rappelle de ça Jerry parce que
les disons l'enthousiasme du public ça
me fait plaisir mais cette folie je ne
l'a jamais compris je l'accepte mais je
suis avec les pieds par terre je n'ai je
ne perds pas la tête pour des choses
comme ça au contraire je me sens
beaucoup plus à l'aise quand je suis
avec des amis et je me sens normal c'est
que je suis parce que je suis tout à
fait normal je ne suis pas une star je
suis une femme normale comme comme tout
le monde non pas comme votre voisin
simplement une question de sympathie il
y a des gens qui accrochent l'écran et
qu'on est sympathique publique et il y a
des autres que n'accrochent pas le
public et on oublie facilement moi je ne
sais pas pourquoi on se rappelle encore
de moi je devrais être à l'écran un peu
plus souvent mais ça c'est tout à fait
notre histoire parce que de trouver une
histoire intéressante pour le cinéma
c'est pas facile mais j'espère encore je
n'ai pas complètement dit non c'est pas
que je ne vais pas faire du cinéma c'est
que je ne vais pas faire de bêtises je
vais quand même donner au public
mon talent
et quelque chose de bien et vous avez un
regard un peu pessimiste sur le cinéma
vous dites le rêve est mort le cinéma
c'est corrompu
ben il y a beaucoup de bêtises au cinéma
parce que on pense simplement à faire
l'argent et on pense pas à faire un
produit bon parce que on croit pas
on devrait croire que le les gens ils
sont intelligents et avec la télévision
on comprend beaucoup plus vite la beauté
d'un produit ou pas alors il faudrait
faire un produit bon parce que le public
l'accepte et pas suivre des
films porno parce que ça ça fait
l'argent ou des films où il y a la
violence parce que on aime la violence
il faut faire des bons produits il faut
faire travailler le cerveau vous évoquez
les films porno vous avez eu un procès
pour avoir montré un petit bout de
cuisse dans les poupées c'était un 63
c'était un film pour pour des enfants
mais on m'a même presque
mis en prison pourrait pour un film je
l'ai montré rien absolument rien mais
c'était n'importe quoi je faisais si
j'ai montré un petit peu de peau
c'était
une parce que c'était moi
il y avait d'autres d'autres femmes qui
ont montré le l'ombelli que l'on met
l'embellie des autres on pouvait le voir
le mien non parce que c'était trop
important c'est ridicule la censure
avant
c'était trop exagéré mais non c'est
exagéré dans le sens opposé parce que ce
qu'on voit à la à la télévision c'est
vraiment épouvantable et je dois dire
maintenant que je suis si je veux le
dire qu'il y a des spectacles dans la
Canal+ dégoûtant ici en France on est à
l'hôtel
parce que quand même la pornographie
c'était mieux avant il y avait des
cinémas ou des gens impuissants ou fou
on avait besoin de ça bon on payait pour
aller voir les films porno tandis que
maintenant on est dans l'hôtel on est là
et tout d'un coup on voit des spectacles
vraiment et pouvant pas envie de changer
de chaîne à ce moment-là faut pas rester
il faut pas se faire du mal oui on peut
changer des chaînes mais il y avait deux
chaînes
il n'y a pas simplement de minuit non on
fait pas ça
c'est vraiment pas nécessaire de
spectacles pareil vraiment je demande à
celui qui est responsable de ne pas
faire la pornographie dans la télévision
ou avant minuit je trouve que c'est pas
nécessaire il faudrait faire simplement
des spectacles séparés ou les gens qu'on
a besoin de sites pornographiques on
paye pour aller la voir mais déjà normal
on n'a pas besoin de s'exciter avec
dévolgarités comme on voit dans Canal+
pendant votre pendant votre carrière
vous avez vous avez finalement souvent
été réduite à votre plastique à votre
physique et en même temps votre
personnalité était très très différente
vous avez toujours été une femme un peu
révoltée qui savait dire non qui
refusait un certain nombre de
compromisions comment comment ça s'est
passé cette est-ce que vous avez
souffert quelquefois d'être une sorte de
sexe symbole et de ne pas être prise
finalement dans toutes les dimensions
intellectuelles qui étaient les vôtres
pour pour des acteurs pour se défendre
c'est pas facile parce que le cinéma
s'est fait quand même avec une
collaboration des gens et il faut
accepter des des projets qui sont qui
sont intéressants et il faut refuser les
autres qui ne sont pas intéressants moi
j'ai toujours essayé de choisir
les projets ou des caractères ou dans
des films importants intéressants même
si c'était moins payé moi je ne
regardais jamais
Jean j'ai regardé les choses qui
s'amaient le plaisir de jouer un rôle
intéressant vous dites qu'un des rôles
que vous avez préféré jouer c'est dans
un film de Castellani qui s'appelle dans
un Isabelle la mère à boire avec
Jean-Paul Belmondo et vous jouiez une
vieille fille
et vous dites comme un regret je ne
comprends pas pourquoi
on me propose pas des
terres
et on me considère toujours la star que
qu'on peut pas toucher et qu'on peut pas
approcher je n'y comprends pas pourquoi
on peut être une grande star mais on
peut aussi être une actrice et moi je le
suis et je suis vraiment dans ce moment
ici je suis prête à faire le rôle le
meilleur de ma carrière parce que quand
même j'ai grandi un peu beaucoup
je suis prête à faire n'importe quel
rôle de caractère mais on me l'offre pas
alors je dois le chercher
[Musique]